by the power of castle hate skull i
[Music]
and you were about to hear the origin
of that particular phrase maybe you know
it maybe you watched he-man as a kid but
i can't take that for granted because
many people of many different ages watch
this podcast and i know for a fact now
that even kids as young as 15 years old
are watching the haters will say podcast
with hella mark harley and just growing
their brains for lack of a better term
kids are really getting smarter and
informing themselves to make the right
decisions about their anabolic use when
they're teenagers so
when i say
the power of castle hate school
obviously that's harkening back to
he-man who used to say by the power of
castle grayskull
i am he-man transforming from prince
adam a normal prince adam just a regular
you know 250-pound
yoked-out dude and they never mention
his steroid use whatsoever but he's got
like a 55-inch chest and 23-inch arms
and is just generally gigantic we never
see him lifting weights we never see him
doing anything but uh fighting against
bad guys that he has to do in disguise
but obviously he looks the same it's
like hey we got that uh
blonde
bowl cut
with bangs on it as well you're not
you're not masking that
and then he's got this uh tiger
that turns into battle what's the name
of the tiger let's find out let's find
out
oh is it cringer it's easy he goes from
like scaredy cat to um
we're talking about talking about he-man
okay
um but you know so my dad this is it
every time i do this it reminds me of
what my dad used to you know everybody
has these jokes when you're a kid that
your dad does and it's like do it again
do it again do it again the one that we
did the most was my dad would say
and he had this great like booming radio
voice and you go by the power of castle
grayskull
i
am georgie
and for some reason that would just
crack us up every single time we heard
it and it's also kind of
uh
a good example of the basis of all humor
is in this
misdirection and surprise that works in
a pleasant way you know you're like
booming intimidating voice and then you
release the tension with georgie and i
assume no i didn't know it at the time
but i guess that's a reference to it
right georgie
oh yeah
like maybe it would be shocking you know
now that i know i didn't see the
original one though so i assume he talks
like that the clown talks like that and
uh pennywise talks like that in the
original one but
this whole time my dad was making an it
reference i didn't know it it just
sounded funny to us as kids do we have
what's the battle cat cringer
we won't take too long
but now i have to know um
you know
battle okay cringer yes
it's just one of these funny things
don't ever go back and watch him in
because it's one of the worst tv shows
of all time it'll ruin your childhood
concept of how good this show was i also
watched an interesting documentary
recently on
the rise and fall of he-man i guess it
was like this
incredible force of of sales numbers for
mattel
for like six years or something like 82
to 86 or there was some brief time
period where kind of like blew up and it
was this number one selling thing and
then it fell off because they kind of
tried to phase ximen out and make shira
the prominent
force of this marketing campaign and it
just didn't really work and it's kind of
one of these
early examples of
companies going woke so to speak because
it was like
shira can be the same as he-man and it's
like but little boys don't want that you
know it's a separate thing and she can
be in that universe but it's like you're
marketing these toys to boys and then
they would also market the sheba stuff
separately to girls
instead of just making her in the he-man
universe on the same shelf it was like
she was with the barbie so then trying
to cross over and make it like hey guys
like it's little boys it's cool that she
was now in power too and you're gonna
see a lot more of her it just didn't
work and it like suddenly collapsed yes
i've been binging on these kinds of
videos that look at
this history of the super mario brothers
design or he-man 80s nostalgia but it is
genuinely interesting because you see
the business decisions behind these
things that i really only have a vague
memory of as a kid okay so
now that we got that out of the way
you're emotionally hooked in because
you're thinking about my dead father
doing something that really warms my
heart and uh maybe you like me more as a
person now we can get on to some
stories
a couple stories that i want to
juxtapose together
to give you insight into where i am in
life and uh this is something that
i promised to tell everybody the other
day wouldn't happen casey did that tell
you the story yet no okay the golf club
do tell okay
because i started okay i posted about it
literally
must have been yeah it was last uh
eight days ago it was monday
and it was before 7 a.m in the morning
so i went to 24 hour fitness i ended up
posting a couple pictures because my
storage is full and when your storage is
full on your phone you can go to
instagram and
like post a story
without it taking up space so i'm like
i'm going to post
this guy's
license and a picture of him just in
case anything happens i don't have
evidence of who this person is okay
that was my foresight but that kind of
set up like why are you posting this
person so i had to be like
this person tried to do this to me and
then people were like what happened what
happened but
i'm not somebody who likes to tell this
story a million times and i figured i
could also
just do it once here tell it in depth
and not have to repeat it and then be
like if anybody wants to see it you can
go to my podcast so
basically
6 47 am in the morning i'm going to 24
hour fitness i find the perfect spot
right across the street from the
escalator so the walkway that is in the
parking garage like you'd have to cross
where only one car can go between where
i parked and the escalator you know it's
eight feet
i get it on my car and in that time this
guy speeds in front of me
maybe behind me i forget where i was but
it was like a near miss and he was going
so fast that it was like
i didn't even have time to be like this
guy's coming he was like whoa like this
guy's going 40 miles an hour
inside of a parking garage
and he honked at me as if i'm doing
something wrong
he then stopped pulled down the window
and i think i might have been like
watch where you're going because he
responded no you watch where the [ __ ]
you're going or or he said
something to the effect of
watch where you're going first and then
i responded but i just we end up going
back and forth
because it doesn't matter if who it is
right it's i would have had the same
response i was actually expecting
a woman to to roll down the window i
don't know why you know you just have
these like assumptions of like oh it's
gonna be an iranian woman for whatever
reason like if i'm being honest ends up
being a black dude in like his mid-50s
um
and
you know it's relevant that he's a guy
and maybe older because
he he dug down in this scenario and was
just not letting it go that he was in
the wrong and that uh you know i
you could have just like i would have
let it go i was about to just walk up
the stairs right so
it escalates no you're wrong no you're
wrong no you're wrong no you're uh if
this f that he parks right next to me so
he's like keep that same energy
basically when i get out of the car i'm
like all right so i
start taking off my headphones
take my stuff out of them i'm looking
around like checking my surroundings
there's not many you know there's like
one person wait on there maybe there's
security cameras i don't know but i'm
almost getting anxiety of like i just
want this to be on record whatever's
about to happen and i mentally prepared
myself that i was about to get in a
fight
um
my heart rate doesn't rise too much in
those scenarios because i'm not like
worried about physical confrontation it
was more worrying about like what if
something goes wrong and there's no one
to see it right i tried to set up my
camera but as i said
it was all out of storage great great
time to be out of storage when
somebody's about to physically attack
you
in the parking garage of a 24-hour
fitness or rather the sherman oaks
galleria so he gets out of his car
and i'm expecting him to come right at
me instead he goes to the back of his
car and starts rifling through his trunk
so then my next thought is he's getting
a gun
but because i'm a tough person i stood
my ground
but really i was you know my calculation
was
he's not just going to come up and like
shoot me in the chest it's the worst
case scenario that he would be getting a
gun but i'm not going to run i'm going
to just remain calm and make it
so that he feels so ridiculous coming up
and doing something like i think it was
obvious that he wanted to whatever he's
doing he wants to intimidate me
he ends up grabbing a golf club out of
the back of his trunk
and comes around the car
like not running but like forcefully
striding you know like like doing like a
big show of like i'm gonna come hit you
but another calculation i made was i'm
not gonna flinch as he swings or does
whatever because he got a little bit too
close like you'd have to right
casey you play golf yeah i was gonna say
is it ping taylormade callaway what are
we talking about
i think it was a driver oh okay um
because i remember thinking like oh he
could he could hit me with the end of it
you know but you'd have to be pretty far
away so if you get within like 45 inches
you get a standard driver
if you get too close it's like when are
you going to hit me with the tiny part
of it you know and i'm just gonna block
it so
it was like you know i was right like
and i'm immediately thinking okay i'm
gonna have to like take him down to
whatever your your mind does go there of
course and you'd be justified and that's
kind of
what i like is being able to justify
being violent towards somebody or it's
like a fun scenario for a man to be in
because
once somebody actually physically
assaults you then you can defend
yourself and you can get away with a lot
of stuff
at least that was my old mentality so he
comes at me and he does a check swing
like at my face but he's a little bit
too close and so i just i don't flinch
and i just look in the eyes and i say
sir who are you
what are you doing and i kind of put my
hands up like this like not touching his
chest but kind of like hey hey hey like
calm down and he goes
you better back the f up off me and i'm
like
but you just ran at me with a golf club
i don't have to back up off you you have
to back up off me
and uh
at that point a couple people jumped out
of their cars
uh two two nice gentlemen who ended up
talking to me for a bit and if you're
seeing this confrontation you don't
really know what's going on but i also
try to stay calm so you can see like
there's one crazy person here and
there's one person who's staying still
and doing nothing uh as the other person
is acting belligerently so they kind of
separated us like said hey let's walk
over here you walk over here and
the guy was still acting a little aggro
said like sir you have a golf club and
it goes
okay and he throws it on the ground
uh as if to be like problem solved now
let's fight and i
and intermittently by the way it wasn't
as if i'm going the whole time like i
don't want to fight you like he's
threatening me so i'm like dude like
i'll beat the dog crap out of you like
saying you know if he says something to
me and he kept saying things like for
example we used to f white boys up like
you on the yard so i guess it's a
reference to being in prison and being
you know fighting against and i don't
know maybe if you are in prison you have
those associations with like oh you know
white dudes are in an area nation gang i
really don't know um
but anyway i'll get to that in a second
because i'll just get through the events
of the story we're separated we're still
talking a little trash like
part of my brain is still like if he
gets around these guys and comes at me
i'm gonna have to do something and also
at various points when he came up to me
like before the guys came in because
he's still acting aggressively so
right before they intervened i was
thinking like i'm going to have to grab
like hit him or take him down and then
grab the golf club i was kind of going
through the like you know like hit take
down grab the golf club which order
should i do all those in uh to dismantle
him and and you know should i whatever
do anything extra on the ground to
subdue him glad i didn't we separated he
goes up
i didn't realize he was going to the gym
as well so he goes up to the 24 fitness
and i try to give him like a five minute
birth
so he can check in and whatnot
but by the time i get up there he's
still checking in
and so i'm waiting at the door trying to
mind my own business but he makes eye
contact with me from the kiosk
and i don't know if they asked him for
his name and address but he starts
saying his name and address to me like
making eye contact like yeah my name's
john smith one two three four five
karan delay lane you know whatever it is
and i'm like did i ask for your address
did i say i was gonna pull up on you uh
which is another funny little thing that
guys do where it's like they threaten to
beat you up you know this happens online
they'll be like i'm gonna beat your ass
i'm like no you're not and they're like
come see me in louisville kentucky i'm
like what like you want to beat me up
you come to me that's the rules i don't
come to you
so he was trying to pull a version of
that i guess uh but he's still just
making like aggressive eye contact and
and
as i said i'm giving him this benefit of
the doubt maybe he was saying the
address to the people who worked there
but then he he he says the line again of
we used to f white boys up like you in
the yard and i think at that point i
said sir i'll murder you um with my bare
hands
so i'm still having this tool like i
want to i am calm and collected but it's
like
this uh tourette's syndrome of like
nobody you know
um just because it's like i'm not gonna
let him get away with that but it's also
now it's super awkward for the people at
the
who are working there you know you're a
24-hour fitness employee going like hey
guys could you not like um
beat the crap out of each other uh you
know on the premise you know could you
maybe walk outside or do something so we
don't have to now be involved you know
because i'm making minimum wage
uh working the front desk at 24 fitness
so
it ends up
kind of resolving there i i crossed
paths with him maybe once more and like
he was walking by me in the gym and i
just did this like
as kind of a joke
and
also to
um you know just be like i'm not moving
and you can you you know what's
something that you can do to like
demonstrate or signal that you're not
going to move from your position
and i was like have a good day and he's
like i'm not done yet
so we kind of couldn't let it go and
also by the end of the confrontation
when he was talking crap to me and we're
still like 15 feet away uh before this
happened i kept asking sir what did i do
to you exactly that made you charge me
with a golf club
what did i do to upset you and of course
he had no answer so you just had to keep
talking crap and that's one of the
things i like doing is like asking the
most basic question and not having an
answer to it
couple takeaways are
look if i'm this guy was probably 55
years old like 5 10 250 whatever
if i'm behaving like that at 55 years
old
you have permission to kill me just
euthanize me because
i will have
learned so little about myself and
reverted back to a state where i have no
control over my emotional impulses that
i'm not bringing anything to society as
a human that's a harsh judgment against
this person but i'm just saying that for
myself i don't know what's going on in
his life and i immediately revert to
empathizing with somebody who's so
stressed out
that they feel the need to engage in a
even
you know the threat of a physical
conflict
at that time in the morning when you're
about to work out but then again i'm
glad he's working out to get out some of
that rage but i just hope
that
as a man
i develop
the trait that i
have enjoyed developing over the years
which is
emotional control and emotional
self-discipline because i think a lot of
guys conflate
acting aggressively or acting tough with
um you know being masculine and it's
sort of the opposite in these scenarios
because he's reacting to me and we both
have this objective of going to the gym
and he's getting thrown off of his
purpose to do this and you know it's not
a pleasant feeling to be that stressed
out and by the way at this point i'm
also still taking 700 milligrams of
trend per week
so
if anybody has an excuse to rage out it
would be me and that's another argument
in favor of
roid rage doesn't really exist
how people think
and i will talk about
you know that in a second my final
thoughts
on my you know
10-day
blast of steroids
uh and how that feels but rage is not
one of these things i think it you know
if you're already angry it's gonna
exacerbate that but i think anybody can
exercise so if i'm on 700 milligrams
which is a large dose of the most uh
potent androgenic steroid you can inject
into yourself if i'm dealing with that
and not reacting to this guy like i
would in the past
you know i i'm proud of that and it
makes me think of another story
real quick quick where i and i'll go
into this on the next one because it's
going to take too long but basically i
got in a fight on hollywood boulevard
with
one of the
celebrity impersonators have ever told
you the story quick
but in that case it was like the guy
assaulted me like came after me
and i was like oh this is fun now i get
to beat the [ __ ] out of you um and i did
and
which character um he played zach
galifianakis in the hangover oh okay
so i will tell that story but like i was
justified in doing it but like again
this is broken my hand several times
getting in fights was about to go to a
shoot broke my hand uh you know it just
and it's generally like upsetting you
don't like thinking about the person
afterwards um he did attack me and i was
justified
in responding with physical violence but
i'm glad that i've evolved to the point
where i go
is this necessary
and most of the time it's not i think
sometimes violence is the answer if
somebody's really assaulting you if that
guy really did come up and try to kill
me with a golf club then of course
self-defense in the form of violence and
attacking that person back to
disable him
is totally warranted but if you can
somehow escape that i mean you know then
the cops are called then it's people
watching then you hurt this guy you
don't know if you could kill him he's
older i don't know what his heart
condition is
and i don't even say that
condescendingly it's like you don't know
what these people have going on in life
and uh i just think it's a it's a better
policy
in general
to not get in fist fights with strangers
in a parking lot okay let's take a quick
break from me talking to you about
amazing things such as
steroids and weightlifting to talk about
kratom i've continued to use happy
hippocratum
for the past month now i enjoy it
several times a week and always before i
come on this podcast it's my limitless
pill it is something that i'm really
enjoying and feel like it's a fantastic
nootropic what's the big issue with
kratom well you don't know what the
source is right you don't know what the
ingredients are if it's the highest
quality stuff if it is what it says it
is and on top of that
do i just want to get the powder or do i
want other administration methods for me
i like the shots i like the pills and
occasionally i'll make the powder into a
tee
i only use happy hippo kratom because
it's a wild west out there and i want to
be able to trust the products that i'm
taking i've had fantastic results with
happy hippo and i know you will too if
you check out happyhippo herbals.com and
use promo code thick boy with three c's
for 20 off try it
let me know what you think put it in the
comments and i'm going to start reading
out the comments
to share other people's experiences and
we're going to continue to talk about
kratom more in the future
enjoy the rest of the episode the next
order of business is i went to tulsa i
shot a music video for hansen
i'm not going to say anything more
because i think they want to keep it
really
under wraps images concepts etc all i
will say is i was excited about it going
in
and i'm even more excited about it
having
been in the project there's a special
guest that everybody's going to know he
was on a sitcom
an iconic sitcom is the main character
this is going to be a special guest i'll
talk about when it gets released oh i
want to talk about it so bad but i can't
because it's going to ruin the
fun and surprise of this music video i
will just say
it exceeded my expectations as far as
getting to the set
various sets that we that we shot around
tulsa
seeing the set pieces seeing the gags
meeting a lot of cool people and then
seeing the footage uh a lot of it the
next day and being like wow that came
out really well
and
it was just an overall good time got to
work out we shot some stuff at a
crossfit gym i went there the next day
and worked out and um
you know it's just cool to get like a
little reception there like when i came
in the guy was like the guy who owns it
um and i tagged at my stories uh
he was like oh it's coda tulsa i believe
is the the gym name he was like wow i'm
so glad you came you made my day and i'm
like me
little of me
making your entire day just by coming
and working out uh but that's cool man
like i'll accept it it sounds vain to be
like
you know to feel good about people being
excited that you come to the gym but you
know
it's also i'll take it you know i'm not
gonna reject that love that somebody's
giving me who i had just met so
let's get on
to a lot of people been asking me a lot
of people been asking me
how do you get on the dark web
i try to be somebody who helps people
out with my free time and not charge
them for stuff you know i want to
empower people when it comes to making
these kinds of decisions
as far as you know using anabolics or
psychedelics or what have you i'm
somebody who's kind of if i'm into
something i'm going to
look into it myself and figure out how
to get on the dark web how do you order
the stuff um
and
over the years i've just found that some
people will adapt and be like show me
how to do it so i can do it because
obviously this takes quite a bit of time
and it's like you're going on amazon.com
and just one click ordering
there's a process and it's kind of a
pain in the arse
wanted to give you guys a quick recap in
case this is something that you ever
want to do first off uh get an onion
browser a tor browser which you can if
you just google tor browser uh you can
download the version for mac or windows
you download it you install it it's just
a it's a browser
that
allows you to go to these sites because
you can't go to dot onion sites
on a regular web browser
the website you're going to type in
first is dark dot fail
d-e-r-k dot f-a-i-l and it's going to
give you
a list of verified websites it's not
anything flashy it's just like a list of
um you know this market this market this
market they all kind of have funny names
you know like
the majestic
garden or empire market or you know i
i'm forgetting ones that have come and
gone because there's always this game of
cat mouse with law enforcement in
various countries trying to shut
everything down so that's the risk
you're playing if you're ordering
anything of the dark web
just know that
by the time you order it could get shut
down you it places exit scan which means
they take everyone's bitcoin who's been
uploaded and run away with it
so you go there
and just start fooling around with the
websites you're going to see a list of
them copy and paste one at a time into
another tab and see what the process is
for getting in and see what they have
that's a starting point that's how you
start navigating this stuff now you're
also if you're gonna buy anything online
you need bitcoin regardless of what it
is some people only take monero which is
very difficult to get because it's not
sold off
coinbase or these other apps you kind of
have to like find people to to send you
bitcoin after you send them an envelope
of cash um
but
you start there and the main bottleneck
is just getting on the sites because
some of them require like pgp you know
keys that you have to set up they
require multiple captchas and you'll put
in the code it'll be like type in the
numbers you see and it's like t x you
know all
squiggly lines behind it it's super
confusing you can barely see the letters
and then you do it and you're like i
know this is the correct thing txj57
and it's like incorrect and you do it
again you're like i know this one's
right incorrect i know you know
and i think that's a built-in feature
some of these websites that make you do
like five of them to prove you're human
and see if you get frustrated and to
check your emotional discipline see what
i did there
so a lot of people have been asking me
how to get in the dark that's it that's
how you get on the dark web it's nothing
too mysterious it's just then you have
to navigate these markets and decide for
yourself
what's real what's fake read the reviews
and uh go through that process where
you're actually taking a risk ordering
from stuff that you know of course the
business model doesn't favor people
ripping each other off but
you're not going to have a money-back
guarantee like you do on amazon but it's
a starting point for anyone who wants to
explore that okay
hater of the week you know runner-up i
want to give head of the week to kanye
west against pete davidson kanye west
has been in a tear and bringing
it back around to emotional
self-discipline
when i see
kanye west
come at pete davidson it does remind me
of somebody who hasn't developed that
emotional self-control over the years
and i know he has mental health issues
of course but
i'm going to go on a limb and say
that doesn't give you an excuse and
there's not a hundred percent overlap
with just your maturity and development
as a person and as a man
and the kind of example that you want to
set for your kids making it extremely
personal expressing a lot of jealousy
and lacking the self-awareness to
understand that this looks really bad
whatever damage you think you're doing
to pete and here's an analogy for people
who come at me online it's like whatever
damage you think you're doing by
insulting me you're doing far more
damage
in
your own reputation because you look
like an idiot
okay so i won't go into it too much but
suffice it to say that if you know about
the beef you know how pete davidson
responded it was like hey man like i'm
sick of being your punching bag this has
gone far enough and this isn't a private
message
if you want to meet up and talk it out
we can do that like men
if not then stop this [ __ ] dude because
i don't want to have to escalate this
but you're putting me in a really
shitty position uh and your kid's in a
shitty position and i think you're just
setting a bad example on paraphrasing of
course but i really like how pete
uh addressed the situation because i
felt like it was very
masculine for lack of a better word and
of course we don't always associate
masculinity with a guy like pete
davidson um but
that's what it is when you look at his
response you know he was like let's meet
up and handle this like men and
meanwhile kanye west is like making
videos of him being decapitated and
uh you know insulting him in rap songs
and just drawing something out that
doesn't it's causing pain to everyone
so
get over it kanye
but the real hate of the week is
uh this guy who says do you think you
have haters he posted this in a video
that
i posted in january of my most recent
appearance on the fighter the kid
he said do you think you have haters
because you are making fun of this guy
when you yourself look like you bathe in
narcissism botox and women's hair
products
now that was in response to a clip from
the fighter in the kid where i said uh
this guy looks like he's wearing a dork
costume for halloween and he was a very
dorky guy and is that a kind of a mean
thing to say yeah but you know i get
worse all the time and he knows what he
looks like and he's wearing
silly glasses and i just you know like
do i think it's it's never okay to
insult anyone or make a joke about
someone's appearance no i just think you
have to be careful with it and uh but
i'm totally open to people making fun of
my own appearance
it's just like be clever be original
whatever
i took the time to break down this guy's
logic
and i like to do this because it's like
it's not again it's not like i'm
defensive it's just like let's break
down that statement and unpack the
stupidity of that statement
your logic is a video from january 2022
in which i joke that a reality tv star
looks like he's wearing a dork costume
is the cause of me being on the
receiving end of a coordinated
harassment campaign that started in june
2021 yes seven months of insults
harassment and threats in my comments
and dms across multiple social media
platforms and directing thousands of
people to give me my podcast a one star
rating without listening to it
that started on the exact day i first
appeared in a non-controversial episode
of the fighter and the kid
that was the
result
of a premonition that one day i would
say a public figure with thick glasses
looks like a dork so what i'm saying is
yes all that happened seven months that
started seven months in advance you know
i went on tfk in june 2021
and because of something that happened
in january 2022
that retroactively gossip
or you know these are precognitive uh
precognition haters right
so
also love the confused metaphor of me
bathing in a personality trait an
injectable beauty product that wouldn't
do anything if you bathe in it and a
broad group of products that despite
catering to a specific gender wouldn't
actually leave my hair looking any
different than the male equivalents you
said women say i look like women's i
bathe in women's hair products
which again it's just
i get where he's going but it's just
weak and it's confused
so i say yeah different smells for sure
but that's not what you said is it right
women's hair products smell different do
they leave your hair looking any
different i don't think so
i get hate because guys like you low iq
late teens early mid 20s insecure follow
the crowd no original thought types seem
to get emotional over my friend and work
associations and physical appearance and
don't know how to deal with it so they
scroll through months of my posts in
hopes that they see something that helps
them rationalize their extreme distaste
for me and end up commenting
progressively lamer regurgitations of
something their idiot peer group has
already said a thousand times hope that
answers your questions so again
i like doing this because i can share it
with you and be like here's the thought
process guys do this and it's like
you're desperate as many people are if
you have a hater they're always going to
look at everything you do uncharitably
and be like see that's why he's a
terrible person see that's what
justifies me feeling this way but
they're working backwards from their
feeling about you and then going oh see
it's because of that the feeling that i
had in you know
june 2021 is because of something that
happened in january 2022
makes sense
you know this is why we can't have nice
gyms casey let's just see what's going
on
this dude this so here's a guy he looks
like he's dressed up as the green goblin
he's got this uh
you know under armour long sleeve it's
not under armour but it's
is you know tight
bright green
like he's dressing up as a booger in the
gym and he's got he's in the smith
machine his feet are up in the air he's
using like he's putting his feet up for
leverage against the sides of the things
he looks like he's got at least a few
plates on trying to do sort of like an
inverted bench press unracks it and
immediately
like fails with it
and
it looks like a joke doesn't it casey it
looks like this guy was set up but
i've just seen this kind of person too
many times
to
really
give him the benefit of the doubt
because dudes do this all the time and i
think you see it with the outfit is like
it's goofy but it's not too over the top
i've seen guys in spiderman outfits
doing this [ __ ] at the gym and they come
every day and it's like oh that would be
funny if he did it once and it was a
joke but these are people suffering from
mental health issues and here i am
making fun of them
but it's it is just a matter of like hey
you're wasting everyone's time and
energy you're in a public space i don't
mind shaming you because
you're doing everything wrong and you're
drawing all this attention to yourself
so i guess what you want is attention
right so i'm giving it to you so in that
sense it works out for both of us
doesn't it what do we got next okay this
is
he said
uh
after that give me 12 where you from
full
and it's a latino dude like raising his
arms up and out like this with
resistance bands but just thought that
was really clever and perfect where you
from paul
where you from essay
what do we got next
there's one of those somebody who once
told me the world
so she
his squat great depth coming up bails it
where is she hitting her face because i
feel like that the bar closest to us is
you see what i'm saying like is she
hitting her face on that bar no i don't
think she hits a face i think it pulls
her by her hair oh oh
no oh there we go you can see like this
sounds good to make it sound like boink
but you're right it pulls her by the
hair
you know now i feel less bad about it
because there are issues when you're
back squatting with long hair where it
catches on your hair and is generally
uncomfortable so i can see how that
would happen and she actually does
everything right she
realizes she's not gonna get it
um without sacrificing her
uh
you know lower back angle so she
immediately goes backwards like she
doesn't let her hips rise and put
herself in a further compromised
position she goes to bale it just yanks
her back
and it's funny
because she falls
then we got this one okay
i forgot because i have ct did i do this
last week i don't think so but this dude
is benching four plates alone in a rack
not a smith machine and he puts clips on
now if you're strong enough to bench
four plates well then obviously
you have the experience to not do this
and know that this is totally wrong um
because if you're benching alone you
never put clips on because you might
need to bail the weight
this guy is now trapped under this like
an extended period of time it falls and
he tries to go for the he goes back like
this i mean that's really another thing
too is like if you're alone let it hit
your chest and roll it forward
don't go for the emergency rack because
if you miss that then it comes right
down in your neck so he gets one on the
rack like the lowest one above his neck
and the other one's
uh doesn't make it at all and it really
traps him under there and i mean that's
a lot of weight when you're exhausted
like to be able to move four plates um
he definitely could have broken his neck
in that scenario especially if you've
missed both of them it's just that's
dangerous because if it gets here you
can't bench press four plates from here
if you can't do it from here um
and
once it's on your neck like that's you
have way less time and a lot more
difficulty to actually roll it off you
so don't do this if you're doing
anything alone
don't use clips because you're always
going to need to bail so
dumb dumb mcgee right there
dude liver king memes of the weak are
not actually liver king they are liver
king imposters
weird this one is only this guy's oh so
i think this guy actually works at zoo
so i'm gonna be careful how much crap i
talk about him
but he says
if you don't have time and you want a
high protein breakfast eat a beef brain
and six raw eggs now this guy doesn't
even do a good job of not looking
completely disgusted at the meal he's
eating uh he's taking the smallest bite
he can out of this beef brain
and a small sip of this six eggs
can we doubt that he even drink the
whole thing because he takes like
uh a little bit of the egg whites
takes a second to wash it down a little
it's totally yeah totally fast it's like
like
on what planet is that the thing that
you jump to you're like man what do i
have around the house you know premier
protein shake or a cow brain and six raw
eggs in a cup
that's disgusting and totally
unnecessary um
but it's it would seem that that guy's
trying to ride the coattails of the
liver king right he's like i'm the you
know
the brain king or something like that it
doesn't work
because you just look at cheap so this
guy's the the liver king the black liver
king we do not like to defecate inside
we like to go outside and take our shits
in the wood you know we like to save
water
uh-oh caught in 4k so if you go to the
liver king this guy's probably going to
blow up too because it's this black dude
who puts on a fake mustache and hair
coming out he kind of looks like uh
kimbo slice actually a little bit he
looks like a skinnier version of kimbo
slice with that that beard he's from
england and all his videos are
like you know like
saying the the core tenets of this
liver king life philosophy and then
showing that it's actual bs when when it
comes to actually doing them like here i
am drinking blood and then you cut to
its cranberry juice
i choose ancestral living
next up we're gonna see the cliver king
which is like the [ __ ] one right okay
mark harley meet with the week because
you know this ultimately is a show about
me and i'm indulging my narcissism every
time i come here and say
here's something that somebody made that
involves a picture of me
so somebody took this uh i was
doing 500 for three on deadlifts i was
pretty proud because i did him dead stop
i'm working on my dead stop deadlifts
and then daniel rabone came through it
just ruined my life once again he put
two little five pound dumbbells in my
hands to make me look ridiculous
which i do like and you can tell like
i'm way stronger than that in real life
so if you see this floating around the
internet just know like i wouldn't be
struggling with that much weight that's
ten pounds it'd be super easy i'd be
like am i even holding any weight
probably not i don't know didn't even
register to a guy like me okay i don't
know man i mean based on this picture it
looks like you're struggling
take it back
we've been over this it's fake news it
appears so you're struggling okay okay
no okay okay let's oh yeah i'll decide
you know i'll go i could do a video of
myself
dead lifting 10 pounds and show you that
i would barely even strain
next one is me
straining on the toilet and what's funny
is this one's actually more accurate
because when i'm on the toilet i do give
it my all i do strain i do make sure
that everything comes out and there's no
doubt like are there still feces in my
bowels if i exert myself like that
i'm guaranteeing that they're cleaned
out
and finally
got the classic scene from
uh say anything me showing my friends
haters will say oh
warms my heart
no no i was doing toto for a second what
is the song he goes um it kind of sounds
like that but it's um
your eyes the light the heat your eyes i
am complete in your eyes i see the
doorway
to a thousand churches
you know that one
not a bad voice out of the kid
you've been holding out huh you've been
holding that on us hella mark singing
next up you know you know what i don't
like about this is that he realistically
aged me
i'm like oh that's what i'm gonna look
like when i'm 50 years old
uh so that one hurt a little bit because
i'm like
you gave me a glimpse into the future
that i wasn't ready for frankly
but i thought it was funny enough to put
here okay
bro science academy
oh and by the way before i do that i
wanted to have a discussion we'll do a
hello real quick
hello psychedelic
i had this discussion recently and i
want other people to chime in on your
preference between lsd and mushrooms
i have taken both
i prefer lsd
i prefer my ability to control the lsd
and i like the fact that it lasts longer
without having to redose because lsd is
one of these substances that when it's
in your bloodstream it stays at a
certain level
a stable level seemingly for much longer
than almost any other compound you know
10 hours or more
i really like that so maybe you
shouldn't do that for your first time
because once you're in it uh you know
it's not going away any time soon let's
put it that way but if you don't want to
have to constantly take something over
and over again or kind of feel this like
we're coming up and we're coming down
which is an experience that for example
on molly you might have where it's like
euphoria euphoria oh my god everything's
right and by the time you peek you're
almost like oh my god it's going away
and there's like a panic element to it
that makes you want to take more and
then mess up your entire next day
with lsd that's not the case and i just
have when i'm taking lsd alone the first
time i ever took it as i mentioned on
the podcast in an earlier episode
it was with a number of other substances
and a really weird slovenian man that
ruined the entire experience by acting
like a total creep around my girlfriend
so
when i'm taking lsd alone i've never had
a bad experience with it it might be
more or less intense
dealing with certain
emotional issues that you happen to be
thinking about at that moment but i've
had other
experiences with i've had really good
experiences with shrooms
and i've had ones that were unexpectedly
bad both on a trip level of just like it
goes too dark or you feel like you can't
quite control your thoughts or it goes
to an unpleasant place and then also on
a physical level sometimes i've had this
reaction i remember taking some shroom
chocolates
and it felt like for 45 minutes once
they hit my stomach i had to lay down
almost like i overdosed on nicotine like
i felt really hot and flushed and i was
like i have to lay down right now for
like 45 minutes and then it finally
passed
and had more of a normal experience but
it was just super unpleasant and i've
had things similar to that before where
i mean ultimately you are ingesting this
thing that i guess you could classify as
a poison
and
you know your body might respond that
way right that is but you don't know
what strain it is there's just more
there's more variability in
mushrooms and the strain and what else
could be in there it's a biological
product and lsd is uh you know if it's
pure lsd it's very reliable so i like
that about it but i've heard many other
people say oh i like shrooms better um
who have taken both so if you've taken
both i want to hear in the comments why
you prefer one or the other and because
it's hard to put into words like people
go what's the difference between shrooms
and lsd who haven't taken psychedelics
or maybe have taken one but not the
other it's actually very difficult to
articulate that besides like just going
well i had a bad trip once on mushrooms
and i haven't had one on lsd so i want
to get at it and see what the consensus
is from other people and why these
things would feel different because the
molecules are the same and i believe
they act on the serotonin receptor when
you look at like serotonin versus you
know mdma versus
lsd versus shrooms the active
ingredients all are kind of in the same
ballpark
molecularly
i don't want to pretend like i'm a
chemist but
you know just visually you can see that
there's a lot of similarities so
let's explore that okay
hella sick fitness oh i wanted to do a
bro science academy that's right
because i just wanted a quick give you a
quick tip on
i worked out with my buddy andy ferrig
the other day he hadn't been to the gym
in a long time and sometimes you just
want to come in and
you know
like kick started with a full body
workout do everything right
and i'm a big advocate i love doing full
body stuff because it leaves you really
exhausted and it also allows you to
feel more comfortable increasing your
pace because what i end up doing and
this is a workout you can do in under an
hour
to hit your full body
um
if you do a couple hard sets of
everything i'm about to mention then
uh
like you can go on to you know from a
push movement to a pull movement you're
not like oh my chest is still pumped and
sore or you know like
painful from the lactic acid that's been
building up
you can design it so
you're not kind of scared or hesitant to
move on to the next thing because you're
starting fresh in some way so
basically this involves
a vertical push and a um
you know a vertical push and a
horizontal push a vertical pull and a
horizontal pull
a superset
for arms a
both biceps and triceps and something
for your legs if you do all that you're
hitting a full body workout okay
and you can go add things here and there
but what we did was
two sets of incline dumbbell press for
your chest
immediately move on to
two hard sets of lat pull downs nice and
controlled narrow grip right a little
squeeze there don't use too much weight
but these are all in the range of
eight to fifteen reps let's say
uh to failure or relatively close you
know consider these working sets not
warm-up sets so i did like one warm-up
set with the with the dumbbells and then
i'm off to the races because a lot of
these i just don't think you need if
you're working on a machine i don't
really think you need a big warm-up and
you're going 10 reps anyway
after the lap pull-downs i go to a
superset where i'm doing standing
lateral raises with like 35 pounds into
dumbbell presses to the front like this
elbows tucked to make it a little more
difficult a little more focused on the
anterior delt
you'd be surprised at how little weight
you need to get a great burn so it's
another superset because i'm going from
a weight that is
moderately heavy in the lateral raise 35
pounds for me to this would be normally
really light but if you do 15 reps
immediately after doing the lateral
raises it's a perfect weight so we hit
that superset then we go into a
row a horizontal pull just hit the row
machine you add a little bit of pausing
on there nice stretch in the lats come
back two hard sets boom you're done you
feel in your traps and your lats and
your rear delts then you move on to a
super set of arms i go to the cable
stack
i do a straight bar cable curl nice and
controlled hit 10 to 15 reps immediately
using the same weight reverse my grip
and go into reverse curls with the same
bar
great burn great pump do two of those
then a superset for triceps just tricep
rope
press downs like this
into
close grip i use my feet elevated but
you don't have to put your feet up on
something do like diamond push-ups to
get a compound movement to finish off
your triceps and then we did some
bulgarian split squats my new favorite
thing because it's so difficult and it
really exposes
how weak certain parts of my body are
like my bad leg that had an acl tear
right it's extra hard but i'm like i
need to get it better i need to get it
stronger and all i need was like 55 60
pounds it's not that much but do 15 reps
of a split squat where you're going all
the way down you're going to feel it in
your entire leg so that's under an hour
that's full body you can add some
hamstring and calf isolation if you want
by at that point i was pooped
and in part i'm poop because i would
take you know after this cycle the 10
day cycle i'm gaining a bunch of weight
it makes working out harder so that's
what i kind of wanted to say is like i
like the results of it with trend you
almost get so full that if you're not
totally ripped you can kind of look like
big and puffy to a degree um
like i saw myself on camera a couple
times in the footage from the music
video and it was like um my arm just
looks like a block
next to you know like it's not
necessarily aesthetic i liked it for the
video because it's supposed to look
silly in a lot of ways it's gonna be
funny but just as far as an everyday
aesthetic i'm like that doesn't look
good so
um be careful when you take these things
because
you know
at least for me i'm always bordering on
looking stupid and i try to be aware of
that and just getting bigger without
getting leaner isn't always the answer
and then cardiovascularly i just noticed
in a lot of my workouts i was able to do
less volume because when you grow and
also trend directly affects your
cardiovascular system in a negative way
so it's a combination of those two
things you're gaining weight gaining
muscle
and it makes the experience of working
out less pleasant i'll be totally honest
like i just felt more wiped i felt like
ugh you know i'd get a headache in the
middle of doing you know bicep curls or
something and just and feel and i was
doing a lot of full body stuff while on
this
on these compounds just to get as many
rest recovery cycles as possible
but something to think about you know
you think all steroids make it easier to
work out some of them actually make it
more unpleasant to work out tren
being one of them
hella sick fitness paid is just you real
quick this guy jeffrey schoenfeld
g-e-o-f-f-r-e-y
s-h-o-e-n-f-e-l-d i think i'm spawning
right okay oh jeffrey shofeld not
schoenfeld
so shofield s-s-c-h-o-f-i-e-l-d
he has a great channel he's a natty
lifter he has phenomenal information so
if you want to go to his page and
actually learn something uh breaks down
really specific topics and also what
i've found useful is he breaks down
other people's programs because
to me this is one of the biggest cons in
the business is like people putting out
these workout programs and they just
suck
and maybe the person doing the programs
doesn't even know
that they suck and this works for them
but it's just like it strays from a lot
of conventional wisdom
in order to make it seem like it's novel
as i've always talked about we have
these people who go yeah it's different
than other programs but you don't need
that novelty you don't need it to be
different and he he does a great job of
breaking down
why these are less than optimal and he
gives honest reviews but he's you know
he's i've seen him break down
greg ducett's training programs i've
seen him break down um noel deisell's
training programs and a few others
like
uh
v shred which is at fitness charlatan
i'm going to get into
in one of these weeks and he just gives
an honest opinion and has a lot of
insight now
the last thing i'll say is
when you see this guy's physique does he
look super impressive now for a natty
lifter if you're in the know yes he does
he has a great body
is he like
250 pounds and five percent body fat
does he look like a bodybuilder on stage
no but he's natty so
this is the thing that i think a lot of
people have to decouple is the look
versus the knowledge and people will
come up to me and i give them that
warning as i probably told you before
that hey
just because i'm jacked or you think i'm
muscular doesn't mean i have expertise
because a lot of things go into that
then nothing about a man's physique is a
guarantee that he really knows what he's
doing or can communicate that to you and
make adjustments based on you as an
individual
and this is another example of you know
the guy is not as jacked and shiny and
oily and freaky
as many of his other fitness industry
competitors but his information is
phenomenal so check him out look at his
workout reviews before you buy a workout
program
and
you know i wanted to end on this
on a help i'm on steroids
but in this case it's help i'm not on
steroids because i went and saw the
batman movie recently loved it thought
it was phenomenal a little bit long sure
i also had to pee really bad during the
entire final 30 minutes so that could
have affected my perception of time a
little bit
i love that it was like a
a noir detective movie we see that angle
of batman that we haven't really seen
before not so much crime fighter and he
did some of that beating thugs up in the
street but solving a mystery it was very
appropriate
uh for the villain of the riddler to
make it like he's solving this serial
killer crime and had these kind of like
seven and zodiac vibes which i thought
were so cool because those are some of
my favorite movies
and uh
i loved how they portrayed batman
where he is in his journey which we
didn't really get to see in the dark
knight trilogy we saw the batman begins
and then we kind of jump into the height
of him as batman in the dark knight this
feels like
he's just getting into it and he's still
figuring out what he wants to do is the
batman and it's a lot more like it's a
small operation and it's a little more
grungy and dingy i like how they
represented things and differentiated
the movies from the dark knight series
made its own and still made it work
the big controversy if you remember was
that robert pattinson like wasn't buff
enough and he wasn't working out he
didn't do steroids or whatever
and uh i admit when i first heard that
it's kind of like he's not gonna get
buffed to play batman um i guess it was
a joke after all like he said like oh i
was just joking about that people took
it out of context but he obviously
didn't
get as jacked as
uh christian bale or even you know ben
affleck went through quite a
transformation because he's been a
little bit chubbier in past years and he
put on a lot of muscle and got leaner
i want to say it's cool to see robert
pattinson not buying into this notion
that you have to do steroids or you have
to get super muscular
in order for us to buy you as a
superhero i bought it it was totally
fine i don't think you need to be jacked
out of your tree
peeled out of your gourd
for us to buy you as batman because
you're already in a muscle suit and
relying on all these mechanical things
to get you through
your crime-fighting escapades so i
thought it was cool that
he did what he could he looked
appropriate he stayed natty and he
didn't buy into this hollywood pressure
that
you have to take steroids in order to
play
uh a superhero because it's not true you
just don't have to and also um i think
it it brings us one step closer to this
notion of just be open about it right
like on both sides if you do take
steroids for a roll it's still taboo to
even talk about it you have to deny it
i'd like to see that open up and say
yeah i took steroids to gain 30 pounds
in six months
um or
conversely your decision not to uh in
this case it's it's obvious he didn't
but it would be cool if you know he had
more freedom to open up and say yeah
they wanted me to and i didn't and these
are the reasons because that can
influence a lot of young people and
ultimately at the end of the day casey
that's what i'm all about influencing
young people okay do i want to hang out
with them all the time no
but do i want to talk to them for five
minutes at a pop and and pretend as if i
have the answers for them to improve
their lives from the perspective of do
what i say not what i do
sure i'm 38 and you know i have a
podcast that talks about the haters i
have online but that's not your
trajectory necessarily you could be
really successful if you just don't do
drugs if you just don't do steroids if
you just stay off the dark web okay so
if you're under the age of 21 disregard
everything i said up to this point about
going on the dark web stay off it all
right listen to your parents stay in the
dare program take taekwondo after school
okay hang out with the kids who don't
cheat to get a's if they're asian that's
even better all right
take care until next week